hi everybody this is jonathan trance i'm
down here in the studio at the st. Louis
chess club and today I have another
tactical challenge for you so when you
see the position on your screen go ahead
and pause the video and we'll see if you
can solve it in this position it's black
to move are you ready black here is
excellent attacking chances and the
potential to checkmate the White King
based on the fact that the bishop on the
nice light squared diagonal is creating
a lot of pressure for the White King and
if only we could get our queen or any
other heavy piece to h1 we'd be able to
checkmate white so here we have a
classic sacrifice Queen takes h2 and
after the King takes back we can get
another heavy piece to the H file after
a rip 2 h8 King to g1 and rook to h1
it's checkmate I hope you guys enjoyed
this fantastic puzzle congratulations
again to everybody that was able to
solve this one and if you want to see
more content like this hit subscribe to
our YouTube channel and we'll see you
next time thanks for watching